in this video we'll talk about
epithelial to mesenchymal transition
epithelial to meselchimal transition or
EMT is a process by which epithelial
cell lose their polarity cell cell
adhesion and gain migratory and invasive
properties and become mesenchymal so in
this example you can see the yellow
cells are epithelial which Transit into
the blue mesenchymal cell they
dissociate from the basement membrane
and now they can migrate in many regions
so this particular molecular program is
known as EMT or epithelial to
mesenchymal transition it's a precisely
regulated molecular process let's try to
understand
so any epithelial cell would be attached
to each other with specific cell
Junctions it could be adherence Junction
tight junctions Etc also it would be
attached to a basement membrane with the
help of hemidesmosomes
epithelial cells would have a typical
Epico basal polarity that means it has
one apical side and another basal side
which are molecularly distinct
now in case of EMT or epithelial to
mesenchymal transition what happens is
the epithelial characters goes down so
there is a loss of cell adhesion or
Epico basal polarity also there are
changes in The extracellular Matrix and
generally the epithelial cells are
non-migratory which eventually becomes
migratory when they are missing when
they are becoming mesenchymal cells
mesenchymal cells show loss of adhesions
loss of polarity and they show gain of
invasiveness or they are enhanced in
terms of migratory capacity there are
specific molecular features which give
us an idea about a loss of epithelial
character and gain of mesenchymal
character
so e-catering loss is characteristic uh
for epithelial to mesenchymal transition
so one of the key changes that happen is
loss of e-caterine and upregulation of
n-catering also cytokeratin is lost but
there is upregulation of factors like
snail sludge Etc there is always
breakage of this kind of lamin one or
basal lamina markers and there are
changes in the actin cytoskeleton so
let's try to understand this in bit more
details this kind of EMT transition can
happen during development and it happens
in our
neural tube so in the neural tube after
the neural tube is closed there are
certain cells known as neural crest
cells which now undergoes EMT and
migrate out
there are also uh this kind of phenomena
reported in ah
layer formation such as mesoderm
formation requires this kind of EMT type
of transition also in biological
processes like wound healing requires
EMT molecular programs
now apart from biological processes EMT
can also underlie
the metastasis of cancer
so let's say you have a tumor in your
hand
and then due to EMT many tumor can get
into new places in the body and see the
new tumor in that location
and this is happening via the epithelial
to mesenchymal transition where the
cells are becoming more invasive and
migratory
now let's see what are the factors that
triggers this kind of EMT there are
Hallmark transcription factors that
triggers the EMT response such as zeb1
twist snail just to name a few these are
characteristic transcription factors
that are upregulated while a cell is
undergoing EMT in experiments where
scientists upregulated these
transcription factors in epithelial cell
in all of these cases those cells get
transformed into a mesenchymal cell
so what really happens when these
transcription factors are upregulated
they modulate adherence Junction in
tight Junction they can regulate and
modulate actines they can also trigger
cytoskeletal rearrangement and most
importantly these factors lead to
production of Matrix metalloproteinases
which dissolve The extracellular Matrix
and it is important for cell to
delaminate from the basal lamina and
move out
now there are specific signaling
Pathways that can help in these EMT
processes in this video we are not going
to get into details but let me tell you
there are signaling Pathways like wind
speed Acadian signaling
there are Pathways like uh which
involves receptor tyrosine kinase and
pi3 akt there are Pathways which
involves Jack and stat
Pathways like TGF beta and Notch Delta
signaling pathway triggers the
production of Z1 twist and snail so
these are the key factors for the EMT
program to start and these factors are
under the control of many signaling
pathways
complex interplay of these signaling
pathway determines or governs when and
how the EMT would occur so this is a
very short video about EMT in a later
video we'll talk about the details I
hope this was useful and informative if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up you can get more notes and
flashcards in my Facebook page and
Instagram page
you can support my channel via super
thanks see you in next video